Ngayong napag-usapan na natin ang lahat ng elemento ng VQE, i-
summarize natin ang natutunan natin at tingnan kung paano ito pinamamahalaan ng quantum computer.
Nagsisimula tayo sa ating maingat na piniling reference state, parameterized circuit,
paunang pagpili ng mga parameter, at isang Hamiltonian.
Ipinasa natin ang mga ito sa ating quantum computer.
Bago maisagawa ang Hamiltonian sa ansatz state,
kailangan nating mag-classical pre-processing ng circuit
para maging naiintindihan ng quantum hardware sa pamamagitan ng prosesong tinatawag na transpilation.
Mahalaga rin na mapakinabangan nang husto
ang arkitektura ng mga qubit sa tunay na hardware para makakuha ng pinakamahusay na resulta.
Ang mga prosesong ito ay kadalasang awtomatiko na, para hindi na tayo
kailangang malaman nang eksplisito ang qubit connectivity,
gate fidelities, at iba pa.
Ngayon, ang gawain ay sukatin ang resultang estado
at tantiyahin ang expectation value, na saka pang
io-optimize ng isang classical optimizer.
Ang pagsukat na ito ay ginagawa sa pamamagitan ng pag-ikot ng measurement basis
at pagsasama ng mga resulta ng pagsukat para makuha ang expectation value.
Ang parameterized na resultang ito ay ipinapasa
sa classical optimizer, na naghahanap ng mga bagong parameter para sa estado.
Pagkatapos, inuulit ang proseso.
Ang classical pre-processing ay gumagawa ng bagong parameterized circuit,
at inilalapat natin ang parehong Hamiltonian tulad ng dati.
Pansinin na sa buong proseso ng VQE, ang mga estado lang ang binabago natin
sa pamamagitan ng mga parameter na unti-unting papalapit sa ground state.
Inuulit natin ito hanggang masaya na tayo sa resulta.
At iyon na ang lahat.
Ang pangalan ko ay Victoria Lipinska at ito ay isang kurso sa variational quantum eigensolver.